okay let's talk in more detail should we
about what labor is up to at the moment
in the form of the Shadow Minister for
housing and planning and MP4 Greenwich
and Woolwich I think I'm writing to say
Matthew pennicock it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning are you tuning into a party
of nimby's absolutely not we back the
builders not the blockers when it comes
to housing and we're going to be
unashamedly if we get the privilege to
serve a party that is committed to
increasing rates of a house building
across the country I I see that and I
know that that's what you're saying but
then one of your fellow MPS Rupa Hawk
celebrating recently that houses were
not going to be built in Ealing she she
tweeted about it good news for a change
glad to have played my bit in speaking
three times against this planning
committee
I don't know the particular
circumstances
I think there are MPS across the country
on both sides who often object to plan
applications I've done it myself where
they feel it's not good development not
in line with local plans that are agreed
by local councils local communities so
we want to see house building rates up
but we also want to see a change in the
way housing is delivered across the
country so that we get more high quality
sustainable development good rates of
affordable housing I think the problem
with the system at the moment is we've
got far too much speculative development
going on that's of low quality not good
infrastructure not the type of housing
that communities want and local people
often don't think their kids their
grandkids have any chance of buying the
homes on these developments so we've got
to change the whole system as well as
reversing the mess that the government
have made by for example abolishing
local housing targets okay so how many
houses a year are you going to build and
how many of those houses will be Council
houses we haven't announced a national
Supply Target if you like we are
absolutely committed and this is the key
key difference well the government you
know has a target of 300 000 opponents
that's an entirely arbitrary figure
picked out there what we're very clear
about is we have to have a planning
system that meets objectively assessed
housing need that's what the
government's Road away for that nominal
300 000 figure Remains the government's
aspiration but they've given local
councils every excuse under the book not
to meet their local targets and you have
to have a system that at the end of the
day meets local needs because there are
people out there desperate to either buy
their own home or to have a secure home
to rent and you know that because you
speak to them so how many houses do you
think you need to build having spoken to
them we think you've got to meet
objectively assessed housing need I
think that will be which is what in the
region 100 houses but they'll all be
beautiful what what's that figure no
because we need a system where you
refine a workout objectively assessed
housing need on a local basis and those
numbers will if you like percolate up
and you'll have a supply Target but
there's no point K are you not talking
to these people at the moment no but
there's no points I think I talked to
lots of Industry experts exactly so I
think there's a consensus in many ways
that there is no point of having an
arbitrary Target plucked out of the air
which is what the government have done
with the 300 000 Target but we want to
get in that region you want to get in
that region we want to get in that
region and even surpass it because to
meet housing need we need lots more
houses that are being built at the
moment and what the government have done
more than three hundred thousand what
the government have done in the changes
they've made
concessionsatory backbenches is make it
easier for councils to pause review
local plans we're seeing planning
consents reducing and all of this is
going to mean in the next year two years
house building rates are going to
plummet that is terrible for our economy
and that is terrible for all the people
out there who as I said are desperate to
have a secure Home of Their Own whether
that's to buy or to rent okay so more
than 300 000 then is the target you said
up to unsurpassing it may do if that's
that's what your calculation of local
housing need is and there is a way to
calculate local housing needs but that's
different from an arbitrary figure that
the gut central government plucks out of
the air and forces down onto local
communities
let me be very clear okay it does mean
as as the leader of the labor party said
this morning we'll say later in a speech
it does mean it's finding the mess that
the government created it does mean
reimposing local house building targets
but as I said it means we think a number
of other changes to the planning system
to ensure that the development is that's
coming forward all of those homes is not
low quality speculative development but
is good development that local people by
and large it back because it's a
different proposition how many of how
many of new houses built should be what
percentage then should be Council houses
I don't it doesn't work like that I'm
afraid okay we will have I think come
the point of the next selection a Target
on social and affordable housing
absolutely because the government has
much more direct control over the
numbers of those built and we have been
very clear want to see a marked increase
in affordable housing particularly
genuinely affordable social rented homes
we want to see a better regulated
private rented sector and we want to see
a much better offer for those who aspire
to home ownership we've got a you know
introduce security across the board all
tenures but behind all of that sits
getting house building numbers up that
means I'm doing the mess that the
government have made and also fixing the
flawed system that existed before those
concessions because after 13 years of
piecemeal an inept tinkering with the
planning system it is failing on all
fronts okay talk to me about the um bill
that's going to go through the commons
later on today at the end of no fault
evictions you guys obviously support
that we do support it okay talk to me
about what uh should happen with the new
rules on anti-social Behavior what
should anti-social Behavior look like in
order for people in their homes if you
just allow me we very much welcome the
fact that Bill's being published today
it's long overdue as I think I heard you
say at the top of the program for
instance has been waiting four years for
these reforms 50 000 of them have been
victims of section 21 evictions during
that period lots of them are facing
incredibly steep rent Rises they will I
think rightly be slightly aggrieved that
it's taken this long to get here but we
welcome those proposals but you're
absolutely right we want all of the
proposals in the white paper that was
released last year to be in this bill
but we want the deficiencies in those
proposals to be fixed what we can't have
whether it's by a very very broad
definition of anti-social Behavior
whether it's by allowing landlords to
say they're taking back the home for
their own use only then to rent it out
or to hike rents to evict people we
can't have section 21 reintroduced by
the back door so we will let's see what
the detail says let's see what the bill
contains but we will seek to tighten up
those parts of it where we think renters
are still in far too weaker position the
the ultimate objective of this bill and
that on this we agree with the
government is to provide renters with
far more rights and protections than
they currently have so if you like tilt
the balance back what does anti-social
Behavior look like in order to for
someone to be told that they have to
leave their home well there is a
definition as it as as it stands in
housing law but what we're worried about
and I've had for example domestic
violence Charities contact me about this
if you have two wider definition of
anti-social Behavior if it's minor noise
nuisance that allows a landlord to evict
you that has serious implications for
particularly vulnerable groups of
tenants so I said it's one of the areas
we want to look at very very carefully
to make sure that the definition allows
landlords absolutely grounds for
possession where they've got very
anti-social Behavior occurring in their
homes but not too wide that as I said it
becomes one of many potential means of
reintroducing section 21 note for
evictions by the back door and ejecting
tenants we got to give tenants the
protection they deserve as I said
security across all 10 years
okay what about migrants um suggestions
that migrants could uh who are waiting
to find out whether they can stay in the
UK or not instead of putting them in
hotels or on ships we could potentially
move them into private sector
accommodation we debated this actually
in committee last week and we objected
it we think it's a very damaging uh
proposal the government brought forward
let's be very clear what's going on with
this proposal the minister who was on
the sofa earlier wasn't the government
are in this position because they've
made a mess of the Asylum system and
their solution is to file the
legislation they've introduced impose a
de facto ban on Asylum Seekers who
arrive by irregular means and then to
house them at taxpayers expense for the
foreseeable future they are looking with
these measures to exempt HMO Asylum
accommodation from all of the standards
let's be clear it's not bringing Asylum
occupancy yeah
yeah but it's not bringing down the
standard in HMO Asylum accommodation to
the minimum it is exempting them
entirely and as well as the impact on
Asylum seekers in those substandard
homes we are particularly concerned that
the government here are trampling on
local discretion these are powers that
local councils local communities use to
ensure the management quality standards
in HMO accommodation is met they're
being told they can't have it and in a
sense the government are just casually
sacrificing these important Powers
because they are reaching for every
lever Possible having broken the Asylum
system to deal with the backlog to deal
with the hotel crisis so there's got to
be a better way than saying standards
don't apply to large sectors of
privately rented HMO accommodation okay
I can see why the leader sent you rather
than coming himself you're well across
your brief thanks very much very much on
the program much appreciated thank you